hey everyone this is dan Riley at GQ
magazine in New York City we're here for
the GQ hang out with Ray Lewis & blogs
with balls as you can see i'm joined by
a few others some of whom you recognize
some of whom you may not but I'm going
to let them swing around and introduce
themselves starting first with Don tovia
at blogs with balls hey everybody this
is done with bwv blogs with false and
honored to once a bit can be doing an
event of sorts a hangout with GQ who's
been in a partner with us as we've
started our our conferences and honored
to be joined by a great group of folks
that will will talk to you in a in a bit
yes I'll start hi everyone I'm lavelle
LaVette 86400 foundation we're a partner
with the United Athletes foundation and
we're just happy to support all the
wonderful work that Ray Lewis and Reggie
Howard are doing and can't wait to find
out about the upcoming events I guess is
my time hanging out today with with GQ
and bwp and he got also with my good
friend Reggie how're we started this
foundation a few years ago and now our
foundation is really Braun I think it's
going to be a good opportunity to
actually speak to uh to everybody to the
fans about doing the things that we're
trying to do it you know Paul Reggie for
sticking in there through the things
that we've been through but now we're
here and suddenly a great opportunity
get to really be all right everybody how
you doing this is a Reggie Howard with
the United Athletes foundation as where
you talk about we start this
organization a few years back excited
about what we're doing and using out you
know the whole team concept in the word
philanthropy so we got some great stuff
coming up next week in New York during
draft weekend we're pushing a nice
raffle to you know give some people
opportune
you actually come up hang out with us
and also raise money you know for our
organization not only for the United
Athletes foundation but also for the
Rays doing locally with the Ray Lewis
family foundation there in Baltimore and
the florida area as we are so we're
excited you know here to talk about the
things that we're doing and you know
look forward to everyone finding more
information about the organization Craig
fantastic well let's start with that
with a little football before moving on
to two more talk with the foundation and
Ray obviously everybody watched you in
the Super Bowl congratulations on the
big win the thing I want to know right
after the football when everything was
said and done you finish your last press
conference say goodbye to your last fan
what did you do that night how did you
celebrate what was what was sort of the
you know the way that you took things
are with your family well thanks but I
had my entire family here at the game
everybody mom my sister's my brothers
you know everybody hand up right after
the game soon as the game ended I hung
out with my sons and my family all day
long we just we went to have to get a
party that we had which I wanna do an
awesome awesome you know gathering so
many people came out Mary Tate perform
it was just it was something real
remember who that you always remember
but you know me and my kids just hung
out I just stayed in the quantum with
them all night you know dance all night
and just really just celebrating and
just relax and at one point did you have
second thoughts and say oh no I just
retired I just played my last game have
you had that that oh no mommy did no no
God series not yet I tell you that I I I
had a heck of a running well I enjoyed
every second of it but uh I knew that
today I said I was done that I would be
done and what better way you know to go
out and go out that way
uh and I'm stealing it all about the
moment that's why I sit down a lot of
listening quiet times because i'm still
in all the moment hi being at ray how is
it how is your februari in march and
beginning of april been different than
then you know in all the years that
you've played football and maybe you're
getting back working out doing all the
things that you're trying to do to make
yourself better the next season what are
some of the things that you've been up
to that are different or that you've
been maybe waiting to do all these years
yeah I think the first thing that comes
to mind you know actually is you know me
actually getting to do all of the Father
things you know I had to go to the
school the other day no not something
actually wanna go to the school for my
son was tough acting up in school and so
I had to go to school and speak to the
teachers and things like that I newsmen
in March that being a march april I'm
right back to training and I'm right
back at it all over again another
training can be false or it didn't
whatever happened but you know my total
focus chains and then now I get that uh
you know take my son to the prom to know
this on to the prom watch him do his
prom things and and just those small
things you know throughout the years of
the sacrifice of playing games so long
you know you're kind of be kind of miss
you miss a lot of it and now I've got a
real chance to get back to a lot of
people that's been sacrifices for me I
think you just outlined the pilot of a
reality TV show that Louis comes in and
has a talk on teacher couldn't imagine
sitting across the desk and say oh no
what did I get myself into right here
the funniest thing ever about that whole
incident was the teacher was sitting on
the other side of the destiny and when
she actually told me what my son was
doing I actually got ready to jump up
and actually put my hands on him if you
look at me and tell me that kids can get
work with love why schools no more scary
so you're learning now
that you have to do all these parenting
things that uh yeah you got you got it
you got to practice a little bit go to
the playbook and figure out what uh what
is permissible I guess right I heard
that your oldest son committed to the
University of Miami to back in the day
when you were making that decision and
what went into that and are you all
excited to sort of have him do the do
the college thing and you know what sort
of advice were you given him in that
decision yeah actually it's funny
because this past Saturday be just a
minor spring game and we went down there
to lose brothers and all this went down
there and you really enjoy you know an
environment of what he's actually gonna
be playing in but I think the first time
you know me I actually talking it coach
golden in him and sitting there cause
going and actually offering him a
scholarship I just think it was you know
honestly as a father you know you
accomplished a lot of things individual
in life but but when your seed when your
first seed can follow you not just to
get into college but to actually follow
you to your alma mater it's the ultimate
reward you know and for me to be based
in full in my whole life and now my son
is one small amount of 30 minutes down
the road that I can share all the great
times you can you know be the tailgating
dad that I will be you know I think it's
just awesome this is where the awesome
to see the transition I can grow up so
fast that's great in talk about
transitions I mean that's a great
transition for us um you know you're
looking at your second career but before
we talk a little bit about that you know
I kind of feel like you've done the
farewell tour this past season for lack
of better terms what do you really think
that what do you want your legacy to be
as as you retire what do you think that
Ray Lewis legacy is 0 minus you know
mines definitely it's very simple you
know that if everything that I'm that
I'm built to do everything that I'm
created to do is help God fulfill his
verdict you know and that is the truly
make our world a better place one way to
another you know this ain't about
religion is in about race this is about
this is about life and selfless it's
about loving our neighbor
self figuring out a way you know how to
re-educate our kids figuring out a way
to you know take away the small diseases
and things that's really attacking us so
all of these issues our issues that's on
my mind every day so when the legacy is
love I've reached so when the legacy is
that hopefully my legacy would be and
that was a man that was first of all
chasing God with every step of my life
but then second there is that the person
is just wanna make the world a better
place and just do it through education
you know I'm not a smart person in the
world I don't know everything but i'll
tell you what I've been together we can
really figure things out you know when
you look around to all the problems that
we have you know in the hood outside
that is in our communities in schools
nowadays I just believe we need more
leaders you need more people to step up
we need more people to take care that
real opportunity to do something
different to make the world you know
revolve the way we see the world with
ball and I think it's gonna take a lot
of us but but for me to leave that
legacy of servanthood is the ultimate
and and so this next transition of life
you know whether you call it what you
want a couple I says it kind of smooth
it's kind of an easy transition because
it's found in my purpose and I believe
anything that's found in your purpose
and you don't have to struggle every day
to get up to do it you just get up and
actually just live it yeah yeah that's
fantastic i would say i like that ray
what you said making the world a better
place and we're so excited about the
work that you're doing with United
athletes and the upcoming weekend we
want to talk a little bit about that the
charity weekend that's coming up yeah I
think honestly what marriage is put
together and it's been through a lot of
hard efforts and things I think it's you
know when you get to the weekend you
actually see more impact you know how we
can start you know next thursday friday
and saturday in in new york and you get
there you see the events that we have
you know the past years and probably
this year's what a little bit ly New
York Stock Exchange filled with FINRA
FINRA about financial literacy and
really understanding going back to
those re-educating people why money is
important in the him a certain
understanding why money is important
understand what financial literacy is
really about and all of these things and
then you don't read educating about how
to take care but how to take care of
their bodies so when I get two camps
most people think I were on football
camp I don't run football camps I run
lifestyle camps because if you can then
take something from that lifestyle and
use it so our weekend is a 24th 25th and
26th on next week don't draft me again
in New York I think it's a great
opportunity because we get to meet a lot
of guys and bring a lot of guys and then
hold for a couple of guys won't name
drop right now hopefully a couple guys
and received the MVP award and all those
things yeah yeah and regular citizens
can get to be a part of this too with
the raffle coming up you want to speak
to that Reggie oh right yeah i'll talk
about it yeah we actually got a raffle
that we put out that is actually helping
the United Athletes foundation raised
money as well as the Ray Lewis family
foundation so people can actually go to
our website WWE United leaf foundation
calm and all you have to do is just
click on enter the raffle and you can
have an opportunity to actually come up
with all expense paid trip to New York
City to hang out and meet with Ray and
the uaf family and you know be a part of
what we have going on that weekend as
ray alluded to we're really big on
promoting financial literacy so we'll
have financial literacy program with
some of the younger athletes at with
Morgan Stanley on Friday and then
saturday we actually have a huge
financial literacy program with the
jackie robinson park and Harlow so
really kind of theme in the weekend
after that and we have a VIP reception
where we will give awards away to
basically MVP performances in the
community and we also have a major
announcement that we're going to be
making in a press conference on friday
about some things that we're doing in
the community redevelopment space so
it's going to be a really exciting
weekend and as you can see with guys
like Ray a part of our organization you
know we have the passion and the leaders
that are associated with us too
they make a real change in community as
a team well lavelle took all my question
I'm sorry about that no no I mean it's
interesting we talk about draft week
what's the significance of draft week
and doing it in New York I mean we'll
talk a little bit about sort of your
both of your experiences with it but
something that I heard it's not just for
athletes what you're doing but also for
for youth can kind of differentiate that
a little bit of the foundation itself
yeah with uaf our real focus is on
financial literacy our organization is
really created to help support our
members nonprofit missions but as an
organization we felt the financial
literacy very critically important not
only to our athletic fraternity and our
membership but also community as a whole
so the reason that we chose to specify
on Friday you know talking to some of
the younger athletes about some of the
pitfalls for financial literacy and
financial advisors with all the things
going wrong with them misappropriating
funds from guys that have done a lot of
hard work to raise their money you know
that's a private event that we have
speakers pacifically for the athletes
and our uaf members but then we open it
up to the community on that saturday was
free open to the public you know where
we have the kids out talking about
financial literacy and educating them as
well so it's a situation where we're
always promoting what we can do for I
athlete membership base but in also how
we can utilize the ability to draw a
crowd to learn more about different
things that matter in the community with
the community youth literacy financial
literacy suppose so that's that's what
it's about so one of the things I think
always gets associated with the draft
right I want to talk a little bit about
draft week itself and the people that
enter this raffle actually have the
opportunity to hang out with the both of
you during draft week we're going back
leg on the football front you know what
it was draft we'd like for you you know
coming out to you and just everything
that goes into it
but it as as sort of moving into this
new life having all these financial
obligations and burdens and everything
else that's coming down the fight you
know what can welcome players expect
that are coming out of college and
preparing for that week I think every
you know situation is different no not
aware you are with your number 100 Rafa
number and 400m draft so every every
situation is different than everybody
entertainment differently my draft was
totally different whether I go back that
many years if not you know I think today
in today's time you know the drafts are
you know the combines are a much more
detail you know you have to if you i can
understand i think most kids have
concept it's a business you know before
anything else before you ever you know
player down and be in international
whatever lee in a failing being whatever
it is that it's a business first I think
when once they understand that then I
believe individually every person will
have to handle their own things some
dope artists so much Sun summoner is
some drop from first-round a fit round
six round so you have so many different
scenarios man and I think that's the
irony of you know the actual
infrastructure of sports is that you
just never know and i think that's
dictated i think what people how they
celebrate is dictated on the noma or
denial you know we are on the g eq
platform and you are quite a sharp
dresser from from what I've been told
ray any uh any recommendation style wise
for these uh these first rounders that
will be at Radio City yeah I would uh
yeah I have some things come around
myself so you know talking something
about that but I just think you know
when you think about GQ I think you know
you really have to understand how many
people you're actually reaching you know
when you walk across that stage or when
you're representing it I think you need
to you need to look up or you know look
the bar
I really understand it you know football
is one thing but one bigger ass the end
to so when you do all of the Walker
build a business mind mess and if I had
to tell you anything no no I don't Laura
baggy coat dad is that is like good
advice dead that that is the only thing
you need to know is to not do the baggy
clothes that's right that's a you don't
even have to subscribe now when Ray when
you uh you know obviously you are the
the face of the franchise for the
duration of your career it must be very
strange not just for you but for the
front office in the organization to be
parting with you and so my question is
you know with the draft with all sorts
of football advice have they talked to
you about you know keeping a
relationship in which your advising in
any sort of way or or anything like that
you know are they going ray who do we
take in the first round is there stuff
like that ma you know honestly the
marvelous [ __ ] with always be our
militia Ramona is what it is true
friends and and from there you know
we'll handle whatever issues come up I
don't know I'm going to be you know
involved in their day-to-day and they
have their own thing going on you know
they run the organization I just think
from a friendly structure me memo and a
very good friends we will always be in
contact so there is advice that he wants
to ask me is definitely free advice hey
I have a question for for Reggie
actually a couple questions uh the first
is let's start with this one let's go
back to Ray because part of this contest
that we're doing is being able to to
hang out with red and and yourself and
some other folks you know I asked him
about his legacy and he gave me a very
ray lewis spiritual answer that and I
really appreciate that but for somebody
who played across the line from or i
should say across the sidelines from
them what do you think that the legacy
is like for somebody who knows and his
friendly with ray and also was a
her with him on the field what can
people expect I mean I mean ray ray is
just a truly passionate individual and
he's one of those people that when you
meet him he's the person that you'll
never forget I can honestly say that
enough he's a person that has the
ability to really inspire others and I
remember the first time that I actually
met with great and we started talking he
has so much intensity and so much
passion you know for everything that he
does it motivates you you know I retired
from football you know seven years at
the clan and he was the first person I
had ever spoken to they actually made me
feel like I would go play again if I
could play next to me Lewis so that's
the type of you know impact that a guy
like Ray has and so when you get a
chance to meet him and listen to you and
feel you know his passion and at heart
you know he's just a guy that you love
to be around you love to fight all about
hundred you just know that when you're
around him he's going to give you one
hundred twenty percent and so you can't
do but you can't do anything but give
that bet amount of more to be associated
with somebody of that stature so he's
definitely from a legacy standpoint oh
you know created everything that he want
to create on the field but i think the
things that wrecked it was going to
accomplish off the field i'm going to be
far more to manage than what he's been
able to complex on the few i talked
about his sort of progression from from
college in to draft day you had a very
different experience and you know we
were talking before you had a pretty
serious neck injury ended up being a
free agent is an organization that like
the one that you're working with now I
mean was your experience again quite
different from raise one of the reasons
that you're involved in trying to help
other players that are coming up oh yeah
definitely I mean you get a opportunity
to really get all type of experiences
because you know as you look at it you
know it's from it from it from the
bottom to the top you know ravers got it
that was highly regarded first round
kick everything that comes with that and
then I always got it um you know was
moving up the draft
collagen had a significant neck injury
broke my neck actually my senior year
and had to come in to the free-agency
rail but still was able to make it to
the Super Bowl as well so I think with
our organization with us having you know
athletes and all sports athletes with
all ages we're able to actually provide
you know our membership base of athletes
all type of experiences you know that we
that they can relate to so I think
that's a great benefits of pro I
organization because you know you get
different perspectives because everybody
situation is different so I actually
pick my neck injury was a blessing in
disguise because now it's a point where
one of the things that we mentioned that
we have a lot in common is that we live
our lives for purpose and so when I
decided to make that pink make their
transition to live my life for purpose
you know this is where the organization
was created and Ray has been there from
the beginning and we're excited about
the things that we're accomplishing and
the future that lies ahead of us right
so what um I'm gonna just jump in this
little fun part of it Reggie you you've
hung out with Ray on several occasions
so this grand prize winner you know what
what can you expect to you know what's
it like hanging out with Ray Lewis oh
man it's cool I mean you just come to
find out that he's a regular guy you
know a lot of times on TV you know
people tend to think that individuals
are certain way but once you have
opportunity you know you'll find out
that he's genuine a lot of energy a lot
of passion and just a guy that you're
gonna love being around so wherever his
opportunity win you know that surprise
are going to have a great experience you
know a trip to New York is big in itself
but a trip in the new york to actually
add opportunity need a guy like Wright
you know I know a lot of people I'm very
excited about that so we look forward to
that person have an opportunity and
having a chance to be ray and everybody
else with their organization and you
know have a good time up in New York
when's the deadline they enter is
actually the 23rd so they go on our
website like said WWE United fleets
foundation
they have opportunity to click on the
blog and they can find out all the
information about the raffle and the
Anika energy today so the ralph is two
dollars per ticket I just wanted to
extend it out to the whole community
gives my one lucky fan opportunity come
up and hang with us in New York great
you've got you've got your ass hat on
besides football is that your is that
your second favorite sport to watch are
you more of a basketball guy they've
been to bend down the Camden yet this
season what's the what's the deal with
the other Baltimore sports con universal
I love all sports like I love
competition purity you know i watch
anything from track is huge you know and
I World Swimming I love swimming you
know I love golf I love tennis I love
watching at all I just love people
mastering the crash so uh you know I
just don't know that but I like my
colors it's a beautiful day out today in
south towards know some pirouettes
alarms today I have a buddy that works
for the UH us water polo association and
he is dying to get you in the pool
commercial I loved one time and I do
some work olo he keeps mentioning it
yeah dance it some information out about
me talking my water polo another but if
you play would hold your feet do you
feed have to stay off the ground the
whole time I believe so yes sir all
right guys I think that I think they
were about to wrap it up is there
anything else you guys want you know
just kind of maybe hammer home the
points of the raffle and everything like
that and then I think I think we're off
but this has been this is Big Dipper go
ahead and there's anything else to say
about that begins for for draft weekend
which is every one knows has become a
you know a huge deal up here in New York
and great for football and the kids
everybody who's involved and hanging out
for that but so go ahead with that like
we're you want to go for a Grammy you go
okay oh yeah again come out you know we
got the weekend 26 that friday and
saturday open to the community so you
know they have opportunity find out more
about our organization and check out our
website www night Athletes foundation
now to work and find out about the team
of athletes that we brought together up
under out you know guys like Ray
leadership and uh everybody's humble and
excited about using the same team
concept that we've learned all these
years in the athletic field in court and
utilizing it in a world of philanthropy
so expect big things out of you am yeah
I think it's very opportunity for us uh
you know now the partners well respect
to the utmost you know who's got PJ and
and Jim Brown you know all of these guys
and the things that they're doing a
foundation based I think for us all
coming together with all these different
errors you know we can touch so many
generations going all the way back so I
think I our I think our stability and
what we're trying to do is what we tryna
you know can't get out of it to the
everyday business person who every day
it's really just our conversation you
know I'm Santa strike up something to
figure out different ways to make our
world a better place but it's gonna be
an awesome time it's always an awesome
weekend I'm looking forward to meeting
the fan whoever wins and trust me you
know you will be in the shock of your
life yeah so anyway thank you guys for
your time yes good this is a you to hang
in you're not gonna dance for us right
can you motivate us that's it no I'm
gonna hang out with Ray Lewis it he
doesn't yell double yet get your ticket
I will get my pitcher take it alright so
this is the GQ hang out with Ray Lewis
and B WB this is a Dan Riley with GQ
dump oviya with blogs with balls lavelle
LaVette Ray Lewis and Reggie Howard and
we are are finished up here thanks for
coming out everybody it's been it's been
a great times a lot of fun and thank you
google for hanging out with us